abone ol
Selam
selam
Hakan bilmiyoruz güzelliklerini
bilmiyorum Ben de yeni yeni Bu yaştan
sonra öğreniyorum var zaten bugün
hikayemizde o ve bugün gördüğünüz insan
48 yaşındaki ben 45-48 yani son 3
yılında neler yaptığını anlatan ve
dönüştü insan arkadaki görüntülerde
gördüğünüz Biraz önce hayatımın
pasta Hayatının her dönemi çok
keyifliydi
Hayat hikayelerine baktığınız zaman
bazıları İçer Her bir film Aslında ve
bazı heyecanlı bazı trajik bazı çok
dokunaklı duygusal
Benimki biraz keyifli ve heyecanlı ve
yorucu bu tanımlayabilirim ben kendi
hikayet
ve her döneminde de aslında keyif
aldığımı düşünüyorum şu geçmişime
baktığımda ama herhalde bunların
içerisinde en sevdiğim dönem şu anki
hali şu an dönüştü insan kırk beş
yaşından sonra olsun kırılmaya geleceğiz
konuşmanın sonunda doğru o kırılmadan
sonra görüştüğün insan
Hikayem
1974 yılında Mart ayında başlıyor ve
ve belki de en önemli kırılmam hayatını
belirleyen en önemli kırılma olduğumu
diyeceksiniz ki herkesin Öyle değil mi
Evet Ama benim bugün olduğum insanı
belirleyen Bence bu en önemli faktör
doğdum Anne babam
sathı kursu geçmiş kurmay subay muharip
gazi Kıbrıs tanesi
disiplini aşırı aktif aşırı hareketli
dolmayı çok seven Hep
şu
şimdi
bu iki insan oluyorsunuz ve bu da çok
özel olan farklı alanlarda kendilerini
geliştirmiş ve
mükemmel bir orkestra şeklinde hatasız
olarak çalışan bir iki insandan
bahsediyoruz yani olan bahsediyorum şu
bu getirirken hayatlarında düzenlerken
işlerini düzenler Ken çok iyi çalışan
bir takım dan bahsediyorum Bunu ben
seçmediğim e göre hayatımdaki en büyük
kırılma Aslında bu insana doğmak
olağanüstü şahıs
E tabii her zaman hayatın her yerinde
olduğu gibi sizler için de öyle olacak
hayatınız geri kalınlık bugüne kadar
doldu farkındaysanız anlattı doman sizin
Bulunduğunuz o kadar çok Tanrısı size
dediler şanslar olacak
O sizin bu şans ve fırsatta neler
yaptığınızı sizde olacak yani kedinin o
tarafında sizde olacak evet bu anne
babaya doğmuş olmak bana verilmiş bir
şans Ben seçmedim belirleyici oldu Ama o
bana verilen şansları ne yaptığımı ben
bilemedim sonrasında tabi Hayat başlıyor
dediğim gibi böyle ört sayılabilecek Bir
anne var spor manyağı sayılacaktır baba
var İyi bir karışmıyorlar Ondan sonra o
günkü Okul sistemi bugünkünden farklıydı
Ben Yeşilyurt'ta doldu zaten bu
havalimanının olduğu yeşil Teşekkür
ederim
muhteşem bir
pro-v
35-40 yıl önce o
Allah hepimize şu spor kulübüne gitmiş
ise biz o çağırmıştı oynamıştır orada
binmişiz Dolayısıyla Yeşilyurt'ta dolmuş
olmakla ve burada büyümüş olmak için
baktığında sonra kolay hazırlıkları
geldi Koleji hazırlıkları gene sistem
farklı olduğu için
muazzam bir çalışmayı bitirmeden önce ve
anneminde bu takıntıları filizinden
yapıyorsam Türkiye 130 ikincisini
sonra ye
Sen bugün bana sorduğumuzda Nedenini
bilmiyorum ama hayatında önemli bir
Kırılma Noktası Çünkü hayatımın geri
kalanında test çok orada bir yer tuttu
ve o gün ben sebebini bilmediğim bir
şekilde Basketbolu bıraktım da olmaya
başladı sonrasında tabi spor manyağı bir
baba olduğu için dedi ki olmadı telefon
spor yapacaksan onu yapacaksın ya da
yapma ve ondan sonra hakikaten Hakkı
hakkını Tam manasını verdiğimiz seni
sabah beş uçları sonrasında böyle
psikopat zorluk
baktığımda şunu görüyorum ki bunların
hepsi benim
babamın ve annemin baskıcı bir
hiç alakası yok Ben hayatımda dönüyorum
bakıyorum uzun kardeşim Evet artık
bunların hiçbirini zorla yapmak hepsi
kendimizi seyret yaptık bu şekilde 16
Biraz önce canlı sohbet edip Cumhuriyet
davet eden arkadaşınız tam canı
yaşındayken yani almanız için de 10 sıra
ördüm
hayatımın en önemli belki kırılması
geldi Belki üçüncü ve belki de en
önemlilerinden bir tanesi
geldi mi
[Müzik]
ve tekrar bir hafta zamanım var bir
hafta söyledikten sonra Çünkü sonrasında
ortadan kalkıyor teklif veren bir hafta
içerisinde
Alman Lisesi'nde Türkiye'deki hayatını
bırakıp 16 yaşında yeni bitirmiş Cannes
takımı Yedi yaşına girerken
bu kalsaydın ne olurdu hiç düşünmedim o
dur dur dur dur
düşündüm o sırada Jennifer capriati
vardı onu dünyanın numaraydı ve bizim
oradan yapıyordu onun yaşadıklarını
gördüğünüz gibi onlardan geçti ve dedim
ki kendi kendime
ben bu hayatı istemiyorum galiba yani
hayatın otellerde geçmesini ve her gün
yeni bir mücadele yeni bir FIFA çıkmayı
kazanan veya kaygıdan beraberliğin
olmadığı bir sporu böyle bir radyatör
hayatın içerisinde olmak istemiyorum
dedim ve Anneme babama döndüm dedim ki
ben fırsat yazmış o
bu sorun ortasında dünyanın ve Kuzey
Amerika'nın dost merkezi olan bir anda
hakikaten Buldum yine Baba kaynaklı
hatırlamıyorum ağzını
konuşmayı da
bu 31 sevilip o zaman bacaklar çıkanlar
ağrı kesici 30 TL sıkıyorsunuz maça
çıkıyoruz yani acıya rağmen oynamanız
gerekiyor çünkü Çünkü sonuçta
varusun devam etmesi için 4'er
bu adrese hep accesspress
çalışmaya başladı Üç yıl sonra Kardeşim
geldi ondan sonra 13 yıl 2010 yılına
kadar gece gündüz bugünkü insanlar bana
bakıyorlar sizlerden bizim programlarını
Sevdan varsa diyor ki Oh ne güzel
geziyorsun Hayat Sana Güzel güzel de
Hayat Bana Güzel olmadan önce bu kadar
değildi yine güzel bir kendi içinde o
mücadelede güzeldi ama olağanüstü bir
tempo Vartolu üstüne çalışma vardı
vardı Şimdi de kendi içinde bir disiplin
var ama artık daha zaten Şimdi sonuna
doğru geliyoruz seyrettiğiniz ortaya
doğru geliyoruz 12 boyunca cumartesi
pazar kardeşimle Omuz Omuza depoda ürün
ayırmaktan gececilere kadar barkod
kendinize
ürünleri yerleştirmek
da aynı anda marketin ne kadar
sonrasında sözleşmeler avukatlar
gümrükler Bürokrasi hepsinin içinde
geçmiş cumartesi pazar dahil buzları
günde 15 16 saatlik bir tempolu şu 13
yıl şimdi yapamam bu
bugünkü Orkun şu an
ve Bir daha gidiyoruz s2010 yaklaşık İyi
kardeşim otur dedim ki orman çarpıcı
size hayatta bir yandan geçiyor Ve şunu
görüyorsunuz Bir yerden sonra Evet bir
şey başarıyorsunuz hedefler koyuyorsunuz
bizim hedefimiz karışmış
olacağız
koyuyorsunuz yapıyorsunuz güzel çak
atıyorsunuz bildiklerimize yarım
kalanlar üzerinde soru işareti
koyuyorsunuz ve yaptırıyorsunuz Biz o
kapanıyor ve dedi ki hayat geçiyor
ilerliyor o sırada çocuklarımızı olmuştu
kimse dedim çocuklarımızı aile geldik bu
işi
daha fazla zaman ayırmaya başladığımız
bir nasıl e e
o çeker o kadar vermeseydim Bugün ne
burada olabilirdim ve fiziken ve sağlık
ve bu hiç bir şekilde bugün bulunduğum
noktada olamazdı O kadar vermesin
kardeşim için de geçerli
sonrasında
2019yılı geliyoruz şimdi işte aslında
bütün anlattığın hikayenin sonu arkada
seyrettiğiniz konuşmanın başında uyku
yaratan karara kırılma noktasına
geliyoruz ve hayatındaki en önemli
noktası çünkü hiçbir kararımı
farkındaysanız bu kadar bir bu kadar
değil bir bilinçle Aslında vermedi
muazzam bir içerisine vermedim şunu
farkettim
Ben 45 yaşında okuma var be artık
gerçekten de
Türkiye'nin en lüks şubesi hayalet bir
şey yapmış uydu kendi 3 Spor şirketi
grup olarak serviks içinde oldu
bu Tokat Şunu dedim kendi kendime belki
iki şey aslında çalışıyoruz İş hayatın
iki tane alıcı var para kazanma
başarmak ve İkisi de çok önemli bu da
yaşayarak göreceksiniz Hatta
görüyorsunuz hayatınızda
çalışıyoruz Ben 45 yaşındayım
düşünüyordu yeteri kadar para ve yeteri
kadar başarıyı yakalamış bugüne kadar
bunun için bırakmışım bunun içinde o
sarma içerisinde sorgulamadan daha fazla
başı daha fazla fark daha fazla başarı
daha fazla para derken 45 yaşına kadar
gelmiş 30 yıllık olağan üstü falan
bahsediyor
ve o gün şu aydınlanma geldi ya Bu
durumdan çıkmanın zamanı geldi aslında
bahsettiğim bu sarmal daha çok daha çok
daha çok daha çok başı
Sizler bugün dünyada
bu konu sosyal medya güzel okul hayat
yaşadığını arkadaşlıklar sizde bu
Sarmalı tutuyor ve siz aslında şu anda
biraz da
kuracaksınız ama bir yerde şunu
görüyorsunuz diyorsunuz ki daha yeter
yeter ne kadar paran var benim var ve
her kelimesini ne kadar büyük mutluluk
olduğunu görüyorsunuz
olmak gerekmediğini en mutlu en sağlıklı
en zengin sizin olmanız gerektiğini
gerekmediğini Anladınız mı bu muazzam
bir mutluluk geliyor Rusya çıkıp öbürüne
sonu olmayan bir çaba devam etmeye
çalıştığımız bir yer düşünün yolun sonu
yok çünkü en peşindesiniz en başarılı
olacağım ilk 1 milyon doları yaptım
ikincisini Ben şimdi arkadaşlar senin
vardı ikinci 2 3.
ben
size şunu fark ediyorsunuz günde beş
elma yiyebiliyorsunuz ve size de o 5
liraya veriyorlar altıncılık peşinde
olmanı ne kadar anlamsız oldu Onun
dışında tam dersi sizin ruhunuzu ne
besliyorsa Maket uçak yapmak olabilir
satranç olabilir veya benim gibi
dağlarda dolaşma kullanılır gerçekten
ruhumuzu besleyen bir şey yapmanın ne
kadar özel olduğunu fark ediyorsunuz bu
yaşlarda kırklardan sonra ben bunu Çünkü
geliyor ve hayatındaki son kırılma
maceraseverler birlikte başladım kendini
artık şirketin operasyonundan tamamen
ayırdığım ekip arkadaşlarıma bütün
görevlerini devrettiğim ve Türkiye'nin
doğal güzelliklerini keşfetmek üzere
çıktığım bu yolculuğu hayatındaki son
kırılma ve en değerli en değerli kılan
olarak kabul ediyorum buluyorum Sizlerde
benim kadar keyifli bir yolculuk
yaşarsınız hayatımızda uyuyorum
bu gibi bugün bulaştırma farkında
ulaşırsınız
[Alkış]